[Applause]
[Music]
what if i were to tell you that the new
enemies of the taliban within
afghanistan are the salafists that's
right we're talking about a full-fledged
religious confrontation and i know what
you're thinking right now but what kind
of religious fight can it be if they
profess the same faith both the taliban
and the salafists believe in sunni islam
and both are extremists what differences
can they possibly have well as is often
the case with a religious extremists
they have lots
[Music]
you see within islam there are four
different schools of jurisprudence the
taliban followed the hanafi school which
has nothing to do with the salafist
school and you will say so how do they
differ well the taliban allow the
interpretation of the sacred text using
reason and opinion and yes i know that
reason and the taliban seem a bit of a
contradiction but the salafists are even
more radical because they say that the
sacred texts cannot be touched right
down to the last comma of course during
the war in afghanistan the taliban and
the salafists had certain alliances
especially with that terrorist group of
salafist profession that we all know al
qaeda however with the us out of the
picture they have returned to focus on
their differences however do not think
that we are talking about an open war
the reality is that the salafists are a
minority in afghanistan in part thanks
to taliban oppression this does not mean
afghanistan is a paradise of tolerance
quite the country
[Music]
as we will see in this video there are
many forms of islamic radicalism and all
of them can be violent and dangerous but
today we're going to focus on the
salafists why are we so interested in
the salafists though because it is one
of the fastest growing branches of islam
salafis has been expanding throughout
the world for decades and that's because
they have the financial muscle to do so
who are we talking about though well
none other than an old friend of ours
here on visualpolitik saudi arabia but
don't think we're only talking about
radical mosques in the west salafism is
also spreading throughout the muslim
world many moderate muslim countries are
succumbing to the charms of salafist
radicalism so the question we are asking
today are why should we care about
salafism what impact could it have on
our lives what is the attraction of
salafism in muslim countries today we're
going to answer all these questions but
first
[Music]
before we get into today's story i want
to remind you that if you like
visualpolitik you can now actively
support this project by subscribing to
visualpolitik's patreon in addition to
allowing the project to go ahead if you
join patreon you'll receive our
newsletter the weekly snapshot where we
touch on many more topics that we do not
have time to cover in video form in
addition from level three and above
you'll receive our exclusive
merchandising merchandising that will
never be for sale you have all the links
in the description and now let's take a
look at some history
dr salaf and mr jihad
we all associate salafism with saudi
arabia however salafism was born in
present-day iraq in the 9th century the
word salafism comes from salaf which is
what the scholars of islam were called
after the death of muhammad and the
salafists were scholar who argued that
the sacred texts cannot be interpreted
they have to be applied to the letter of
the law and you may be wondering what
does salafism have to do with saudi
arabia well all comes from the 18th
century when a cleric by the name of
al-wahab converted the most important
tribal chief of the area only that
instead of calling it salafism in an act
of modesty he called it wahhabism
because clearly the last thing he wanted
to do was to be famous the rest is
history
[Music]
in 1930s saudi arabia discovered that
they held all the dinosaur juice to
produce and sell suddenly a lot of
immigrants from other muslim countries
migrate to work in the saudi oil fields
and between barrels of oil and daily
prayers they ended up converting to
salafism
but not only that what do all the saudis
do with all the money that they make
from oil well this is where the big
saudi gap comes in which we've already
told you about here several times on
visualpolitik the saudi royal house uses
the money to live the high life buying
mansions and luxury cars yep okay they
uphold certain religious conventions but
they forget the whole part of salafism
that says to be austere and modest in
contrast we have the true salafists the
real ones those who no matter how rich
they are will never wear an armani suit
because it goes against their holy texts
these salafists use their money to
spread their word all over the world and
of course some will ask what's wrong
with one religion expanding that's
normal well yeah you're right the
problem is that within salafism there
are branches that preach violence yes
visualpolitik fans we are talking about
jihadism
[Music]
however let's take a moment because
jihad is rather unknown as a term in the
west there are actually two levels of
jihad the lesser jihad consists of
fighting the infidel in this case anyone
who does not practice salafism and in by
most cases we mean fighting by violent
fighting but then there is the greater
jihad greater jihad consists of the
internal struggle against the greatest
and fidel there can be which is oneself
the internal struggle to control our own
desires and to be faithful to the quran
in other words many times we hear a
muslim cleric talking about the jihad
and that does not necessarily mean that
he is talking about killing infidels
with this clarification in mind there is
something that many of you may be
wondering now how is it possible for
such a radical religion to expand so
quickly well we're going to take a look
at that right now
the expansion of salafism evil version
[Music]
it's no surprise that religion is used
as a political weapon it has been done
throughout history so when all of north
africa became independent from their
european colonisers the salafists
thought they had a growth opportunity
and you will say so did it work out well
well the answer is actually no not at
all it went badly
when algeria was at war with france the
salafists had a certain moment of glory
but as soon as algeria became
independent salafist parties were
marginalized during the india-pakistan
war both saudi arabia and qatar funded
salafis terrorist groups but they barely
achieved real political power and in
afghanistan it was a real failure
[Music]
first the communists stopped any
religious movement then the taliban
stopped the salafists during the latest
afghan war the salafists had achieved a
certain presence in this case their main
supporter was the islamic state in
khorazan province but as soon as the
taliban seized all power the salafists
were the first victims check this out
taliban takes on iskp the most serious
foe in afghanistan and it was a similar
story with the arab springs neither
indonesia nor in egypt have they managed
to expand yes of course in all these
countries there are some salafist
political parties but in tunisia they
don't win elections and in egypt there
are no elections to win however there is
one area where salafism is indeed
gaining ground and we're going to take a
look at that now
how to spread a religion
[Music]
okay it has become clear to us that the
saudi regime wants to spread salafism
the question is why not rein in their
saudi royal house after all the united
states has more than enough tools to put
pressure on them but here comes the big
plot twist in this story is it really
the saudi regime that is funding the
salafist mosques
well yes and no at the same time saudi
arabia donates money to islamic ngos
such as for example the muslim world
league on paper this is just
humanitarian aid but many of the people
in charge of these ngos divert money to
the jihadist cause however the bulk of
the financing of international salafism
comes from civil society that's right
much of the funding of salafist mosques
outside saudi arabia comes from the
private sector that is from those true
salafists who have nothing to do with
the saudi royal house
we're talking about bankers real estate
entrepreneurs and civil servants with
very high salaries instead of using
their money to buy mansions in the
mediterranean they use it to build
mosques in chechnya and you will say
surely they're in cahoots with the saudi
regime right well the truth is that they
are not as we said at the beginning the
true salafists hate the saudi royal
house they consider them to have sold
out for the comforts of the infidels and
i'll give you an illustration of this at
the political level saudi arabia and
qatar are at each other's throats this
is visualpolitik 101 however the true
salafists do not understand borders both
qataris and saudis go hand in hand when
it comes to building mosques religion is
far above the interests of the various
royal houses mind you the saudi royal
house has done virtually nothing to
prevent these moves but that is another
story by now you are probably anxious to
know where salafism has managed to
succeed well pack your bags because we
are going to chechnya
[Music]
chechnya is a region of russia famous
for its concentration camps for
homosexuals for centuries the chechens
professed sufi islam and how does the
lafayette penetrate these regions you
may ask three simple reasons war poverty
and social exclusion
and you may be wondering what war has
chechnya had well one against mother
russia itself chechnya unilaterally
declared independence and moscow
responded by sending its army to their
door this was the first russian chechen
war which ended the lives of more than
40 000 in a territory of one million
inhabitants it was a tough blow and
after the repression russia began
economically isolating chechnya without
money from russia chechnya had no choice
but to accept money from saudi arabia
qatar and kuwait thus came the first
salafist mosques
think about it we are not just talking
about a mosque where you go to pray we
are talking about schools where children
are educated for free or for
ridiculously low prices between a math
lesson and a geography lesson they threw
in a bit of salafism that is to say
salafism is more than a religion it also
offers some social benefits this is
especially attractive in war-torn places
and all of this explains why years later
when the second russian chechen war
broke out the salafists ended up
establishing the caucus emirate this
emirate eventually dissolved after the
money from international jihadism all
went to the islamic state even many
chechens ended up leaving for syria
however now salafism is at a low ebb why
well thanks to our good friend putin and
his even better friend razdan karav who
we have talked about previously on
visualpolitik
[Music]
kadarov is a warlord who rules chechnya
with putin's support basically putin
once told cataract you do whatever
nonsense you want inside your territory
but i don't want to see a single
terrorist in the rest of russia and
kadarov has taken that to heart in fact
he has a message for all chechens who
have gone to the islamic state
seems like a fun guy right i'll give you
a piece of advice if kadyrov says that
he will personally take care of your
annihilation listen to him this man's
story is one to shudder at of course
chechnya is still an extremely poor
place and some areas have kept their
mosques but it's not clear for how long
however chechnya is not the only
territory where salafism had spread
where else would you imagine it has been
successful as many of you may have
guessed it's in central asia that is in
the stands more specifically tajikistan
and kurdistan
in these two countries almost 30 percent
of the population are supporters of
salafism that's more than 4.5 million
people are they all violent no they're
not the islamic movement of uzbekistan
does practice the lesser jihad but
mainly salafism in this area has a name
an unpronounceable name by the way
tatarir we were talking about a
political party that was born in the 90s
and why do they have so many supporters
mainly for one reason their discourse
against corruption that's right the
salafis seem to be enough on the outside
for their anti-corruption rhetoric to be
taken seriously from that starting point
the rest of the religious discourse is
much better received but now the
question you're all asking yourselves is
unless you are razdan kadarov is it
necessary to fight the spread of
solacism to what extent is this a real
problem
fighting terror or fighting beliefs
the world has indeed a united against
jihadist salafism that is to say against
terrorists to give you an idea of the
magnitude of the problem just look at
the data between 2002 and 2014 the main
jihadist salafist groups that is the
islamic state its affiliate in nigeria
boko haram and al qaeda took just over
54 000 lives almost all of these victims
were not from western countries but from
the muslim world itself and how is this
possible you may ask well because as we
said before for a jihadist salafist an
infidel is anyone who is not salafist
and that includes other muslims the same
is true in the west i don't need to
remind you of the long list of attacks
we have suffered throughout europe and
yes all over europe we have a lot of
radical mosques check this out
brussels great mosque and ties with
salafism brussels largest mosque is
bankrolled by saudi arabia a salafist
regime mosque leaders have disassociated
themselves from terrorism but are not
revealing anything and this is what is
happening in belgium do you know what
the french have done their security
forces have infiltrated the offices of
mosques and discovered how many clerics
use radical rhetoric in fact between
2012 and 2015 they expelled 52 clerics
from the country for this reason
okay jihadist terrorism is combated and
so is radicalization but what about
salafism as a religious doctrine well at
this point in time you could say that
the muslim world is going through its
own cultural battle that's right
tilapism is not the only islamic
doctrine that is trying to expand its
influence there are many groups around
the world that are dedicated to fighting
against slavism by disproving its
discourse and actions one of them is in
indonesia and they are called nadidol
ulama it's estimated that they have
between 40 and 90 million followers in
indonesia alone because indonesia is the
country with the largest muslim
population in the world now that does
not mean all these organizations are not
radical some of them even pose problems
for the governments of the countries in
which they operate in the meantime the
only option that seems viable today is
to fight terrorism that is leave
religion aside and focus on the
terrorist cells and for the moment
coordinated action between countries is
working relatively well since 2014
terrorist attacks have been reduced by
60 worldwide and this is good news for i
mean everyone who's not terrorist but
now it's over to you do you think this
is enough should we put more pressure on
saudi arabia to prevent it from funding
jihadist groups you can leave me your
answer in the comments below as always
don't forget that here on visualpolitik
we release new videos every week so
subscribe to the channel and hit the
little bell down there so you don't miss
any of our updates and of course
remember that you can actively
collaborate with this project by
becoming a patron if you like this video
like it so we find out and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you